COREY GOLDFEDER: Hi, welcome to
Apps, Add-ins and more with
Apps Script.
If you can say that
three times fast
I'll give you a cookie.
I'm Corey.
I'll be presenting this.
I'm an engineer in Google
Apps Script.
I'll be presenting along with
Drew who's also an Apps Script
engineer and James Ferreira
who's one of our users.
Before we begin, here are
some important links.
If you like to tweet about the
conference, or even Buzz,
io2011 for the conference,
googleapps for the track.
And if you'd like to give us
feedback, there's a short link
up there, please go
ahead and use it.
OK, so let's begin.
Can I get a show of hands, has
anyone in the audience used
Google Apps Script?
Not bad, not bad.
Those of you at home on YouTube,
you can also raise
your hands if you like.
We won't be watching, but it
makes you feel part of the IO
experience.
So let's define some terms.
An add-in, an
app, and app script.
Well, an add-in is an extension
to Google Apps that
provides integrated
glue-logic.
Think of it as a plug-in adding
functionality to an
existing Google App.
An app on the other hand, is a
full scale application with
its own user interface at its
own URL that interacts with
the rest of the Google
Apps suite.
An apps script is Google's
cloud scripting language,
which lets you build both
add-ins and apps that live
entirely in the cloud
and participate in
the Google Apps suite.
This is Bob.
Those of you who came to our
IO session last year may
remember Bob as the guy who
automated everything at Acme
Corp. Well, Bob no longer works
for Acme Corp. Don't
worry, he wasn't fired.
In fact, he did so well
that he retired.
Then the housing bubble came and
all of Bob's friends were
losing their homes.
So Bob sprang into action as
a second career helping his
friends refinance
their mortgages.
Sure, why not?
The problem is that this is
pretty labor intensive and Bob
is a guy who doesn't like
to do a lot of labor.
So today, we're going to help
Bob build a mortgage
calculator.
It's going to automate a lot
of his workflow process.
This is going to involve a lot
of pieces, from debugging to
GUIs, to how to deploy an app,
using Gmail, writing
documents, things like blobs
and conversions that will
become clearer as we
go through then.
So let's step through it
one piece at a time.
Here's the app we want
build today.
This is Bob's calculator.
On the top left is a panel
showing emails from Bob's
Gmail accounts that have
something to do with
refinancing a mortgage.
Below that is a panel showing
the most recent--
I'm sorry, the currently
selected email.
And on the top right is a
mortgage calculator where Bob
can fill in the amount, the
rate, and the years.
Or even have it auto-populated
from an email.
On the bottom is a
button that says,
generate reply with quote.
When Bob clicks that button, the
person who got the email
gets back from him a quote
for a new mortgage.
Looks pretty cool.
How do we build it?
Well the first thing we need is
to talk about the basics of
a Mortgage calculation app
and how to debug it.
This is a calculate monthly
payment function.
You take in the principal, the
amount of money, the rate, and
the number of years of the term
of the loan and it gives
you back the expected
monthly payment.
And I'm not going to
lie, I took this
directly from Wikipedia.
Now if you test this according
to Wikipedia with $100,000 at
a 4.0 rate and 30-year mortgage,
you should get a
$477 monthly payment.
So let's see what happens.
We run the function.
Take a look at the logs.
And that is not the value
that Wikipedia
told us would be there.
Something's wrong.
Well luckily for us, this
year Google Apps
Script launched a debugger.
We can set a break point and
start debugging and see what's
going on at every
line of code.
Like any other debugger,
we have step into, step
over, and step out.
And here we're using step into
to step through the code line
by line, see the values changing
in the bottom panel
as the code executes.
That looks good.
Still looking good.
And the denominator is clearly
wrong on the bottom.
OK, well we can fix that.
Let's get out of
debugging mode.
Ah, there it is.
As with everything else, a
misplaced parenthesis is the
problem with our program.
OK, so we can fix it.
Run it again.
And there it is, the value
that God and Wikipedia
intended, $477.
Great, we have a calculate
monthly payment function.
But of course, we don't want Bob
to have to come into the
script and edit the code every
time he wants to calculate a
new monthly payment.
What we need is a GUI.
Now, here's another question for
you guys, how many of you
have tried to build a
UI using Google Apps
Script, using UiApp?
OK, a few people.
It's pretty difficult because
you have to construct your
entire UI in code, which
is sometimes
complicated and painful.
Which is why today, we're happy
to announce the Apps
Script GUI Builder.
This is a drag and
drop GUI Builder.
I'm sure you're familiar
with the type.
You can create a UI in it, use
it from Apps Script, and this
is live today.
You can go turn it on right now,
it's in the file menu and
we'll show it to you
in a minute.
[APPLAUSE]
COREY GOLDFEDER: So what can
the GUI Builder do for you?
Well of course, it can let you
build a user interface easily.
It could also let you decorate
it later, and
this is really important.
You can build a functional
interface, make it work, and
then worry about styling
it after the fact.
You can script it as usual,
and we're going to go into
that in detail in a moment.
And finally, as with everything
in Google Apps
Script, you can deploy it fast.
We barely have the word
deploy in our dictionary.
One-click deployment is
what we're all about.
The GUI Builder helps you
reduce development time
because you can iterate quickly
on the UI as you're
building the script.
It also reduces code size
because you can separate out
the UI and the styling from
Business Logic and in fact,
you don't even need to have
explicit code for your UI, it
just works.
And finally, it actually helps
you with the correctness of
your code because the Builder
helps you avoid
common UiApp pitfalls.
You can't put widgets in panels
that don't support
them, you can't set values
that aren't allowed.
The Builder prevents common
UI of errors.
And if it works in
the Builder, it
will work in UiApp.
Building a GUI should be fast
and intuitive because you guys
are focused on application
design, not on website design.
You don't want to deal
with CSS quirks.
You don't want to deal with
setting values browser by
browser, so we do
that for you.
The GUIs real WYSIWYG
down to browser
quirks like I just said.
On the left is a UI from the
Builder showing in Firefox.
On the right is the same
UI showing in Chrome.
Notice that there are
slight differences.
These are done by the browser,
so they look native to each
browser in each OS.
However, the functionality
will be the same.
Most importantly, what you see
in the Builder is what you
will see in that browser.
So if you open this same UI in
Chrome, you will see the app
as it will show in
running Chrome.
If you open in Firefox, you will
see it as it shows if run
in Firefox.
I have not mentioned Internet
Explorer because we support
all modern standard compliant
browsers.
We do have rudimentary Internet
Explorer support and
more should be coming, but it
works right now very well in
Firefox and Chrome.
OK, so how do you build a UI?
You can use Draw or Drag
to create widgets.
Dragging's when you just click
on the pallet, drag a
widget right off.
Drawing is when you select an
item on the pallet, carefully
place and draw like you were
drawing in a paint program.
And these are the same widgets
as in UiApp, so you should be
immediately familiar
with them.
Not all the UiApp widgets
are available.
You can expect the rest of them
to come shortly and more
widgets to be added both to the
Builder and UiApp in the
days to come.
You can lay out or group
widgets using panels.
Nested panels can create complex
effects and flow
panels, like Flow Panel or
Vertical Panel, et cetera, can
let you create resolution
independence using both flow
panels and percentage sizing
so that your UIs show up
correctly on everything
from mobile
devices to large screens.
You can even try different
resolutions without resizing
your browser.
Because as we'll see in a
moment, there's an application
window inside the Builder that
can be independently re-sized.
And a lot more of this is coming
too in future versions
of the near future, you can
expect things like snap to
grid, dragging guidelines as you
drag near something, all
that is on its way.
Each widget in the Builder
exposes only the properties
that it supports.
So you can focus on exactly
what you need.
And also, so that you can't
set a value that
won't make any sense.
Everything is checked as you
type, every value is validated
and you get immediate
feedback.
You see the effect in the
Builder as you type it and if
it can't be applied to that
property, to that widget, it
won't be saved.
So if it works in the Builder,
it will work in your app.
And finally, you can add
behaviors, event handlers,
directly from the Builder
and we'll see an example
of that right now.
So here's the Builder.
We load it from the file menu.
That menu item is live today.
And here it is, a floating
application window.
On the right side is a
properties bar, editable
properties.
On the left side is a
widget palette with
more widgets to come.
Let's start building Bob's
mortgage calculator.
Just the simple building
blocks.
A flow panel to hold the
emails as they come in.
An absolute panel for the
calculator, top right area.
And a label at the bottom to
hold the text of the currently
selected email.
Once we've dropped items on the
application, we can edit
them either by dragging them
or resizing them as so.
Or, by using the Properties
bar to edit the currently
selected widget or widgets.
Changing the text, everything
is changed live.
Changing the color.
If you edit it here, you'll see
the result immediately.
So how are we going to interact
with this UI in code?
If we want to get a reference
to an element in the UI, we
need to use its ID property.
So let's set some IDs.
The top left panel, well that's
the emails panel.
The top right panel, that's
the calculator.
Great, so now we have
references that
we can use in code.
Let's actually start building
the calculator.
We'll need a calculate button.
Rip it off, place it
where we like it.
We'll give it an
ID, some text.
Great.
And of course, some behavior.
The GUI Builder is aware
of your script.
So all the function in your
script are available to set as
event time that is right
there in the Builder.
When you click on Calculate,
the calculate function will
now be called.
Oh, and we need a button
at the bottom for
that reply with quote.
Same thing.
Replace it, re-size it, give it
an ID, give it some text,
wait for the video to
catch up with me.
Generate reply with
quote, and so on.
OK, so let's go back to the
calculator on the top and
continue building that.
We'll need some labels
for the fields.
And notice as these are drawn
that the component tree in the
top right is showing you the
hierarchy, the panel based
hierarchy of your UI.
You can actually select
things and edit them
directly from that tree.
We need a label for
the results.
We'll put a dollar sign in there
so that it looks nice
when there's nothing
showing yet.
And some text boxes to hold
the actual fields.
Now, as I said before, the way
you get it referenced to an
element in the UI is
through its ID.
So we're going to set the ID as
Text Amount, Text Rate, and
Text Years.
And of course, we'll set
the labels to match.
This next part is really
interesting.
Each email that came in showed
its from and its subject on
its own row.
What we're going to do now is
build a single email row,
which we can use as a template
to stamp out multiple copies
of the same piece of the UI.
So here we put a flow panel,
we call it row, and we're
going to copy that over
and over in the app.
We set some sizing on it, 100%
width, get rid of its border.
And now let's drop some
labels on it.
A label for From and a
label for Subject.
And you can see that the
interaction with these widgets
is pretty natural.
You size them or you edit them
as you'd expect in any other
application.
A label for subject.
Notice the blue boxes.
The blue box shows where
the widget will go when
you let go of it.
So if you're dragging it or
resizing it, that's where it
will end up.
When you're doing this on an
absolute panel, it's not the
most obvious thing because
it's directly behind what
you're dragging.
When you're working on a flow
panel, it's actually really
helpful to see the entire UI
re-flowing as you're dragging.
We have From, we have Subject.
Great.
100% width.
And now let's just
add some styling.
From should be bold.
And let's drag all the
widgets that we want
to be the same color.
Select them all with Control.
Set a nice color.
And this is the decorate it
later part that I mentioned.
Once we built the UI, we can
worry about the way it looks.
Nice yellow backgrounds.
A different color for the
label at the bottom.
And there it is, Bob's
calculator app, exactly as we
showed it before.
So, we can build a UI.
What can we do with
it in script?
The first thing we need to do
with a Builder component, and
here I'm going to
define a term.
We call the UI you just
built a component.
The first thing you can do
is load it in with a new
function, UiApp loadComponent.
Everything you do in the Builder
has 100% compatibility
with UiApp code and components
act exactly as if you had
typed in the code
to create them.
Here's how you show the app,
show the UI you just created
as its own web page.
This is standard if you ever
use UiApp or if you look at
our existing UiApp code.
You write a doGet function.
You create an application,
var app equals
UIapp.createApplication.
You add to it the loaded
component.
And this is the only new part,
app.loadComponent.
And you return the app.
This will show that UI
that you just created
as its own web page.
Well, we can do more
than that.
Builder components can be
edited in apparently.
Builder components can be edited
in something, in code.
Here we're loading a component
in from the GUI.
We're grabbing a single
widget from it.
So we're using the IDs that I
mentioned, app.getElementbyID
and grabbing out button one.
And then we're changing
the text.
So were editing the UI
from the Builder.
It's not static.
You can use it just as if you
had created the code yourself.
You can also add new UiApp
widgets inside
of a Builder component.
So here we're loading
a component.
Grabbing out panel one from it,
again same way as before,
using its ID to get
a reference to it.
And then adding a new
button inside.
And this button is completely
a UiApp.
This is not from the Builder.
So UiApp and the Builder
can totally interact.
You can even pull out parts
of a component.
Here we're loading a component,
grabbing a panel.
Again, an inner panel, not
the entire component.
And only adding part of the
component to the app.
The only part that will
show now in the app
is that inner panel.
And I'll show an example
of this in a
moment actually working.
Finally, you can add the
same component to the
app multiple times.
This how we achieve using that
row as a template over and
over again.
Now of course, there's a problem
because every element
in a UiApp must have
a unique ID.
And these IDs are coming
from the Builder.
So you can use the optional
prefix property and set a
prefix for each version
that you load in.
No longer will there be
a calculate button.
There'll be a one calculate
and a two calculate.
And this is how we can
distinguish them in code.
Great.
So now we've built a UI for
Bob's mortgage calculator.
How can we get this application
out to the world?
How can we deploy it?
So there are a couple different
ways that code from
Google Apps Script
can be deployed.
The first is as an add-in,
either to a spreadsheet or
more recently to a Google site
with more integrations coming.
In a spreadsheet you can use is
at the custom function, or
as a dialogue with its own user
interface that might be
raised from an integrated
user menu.
And the key here is when you're
publishing a Google
Apps Script as an add-in,
it runs as
the user at the keyboard.
What does that mean?
It means that when you load
a spreadsheet that has an
add-in, you, the guy running the
spreadsheet, are the user
who's being referenced
by the script.
So if it's referencing contacts
or calendar, it's
referencing your contacts
and your calendar.
In contrast, the other way to
publish a Google Apps Script
piece of code is as an app on
its own with its own URL and
its own user interface not
inside of an existing app.
In that case, it executes
as the publisher.
And this is ideal for
things that want to
be run as role accounts.
So if, for example, you build
an HR based system, you can
always run it as HR
at your domain.
Let's see what it looks like
to do a custom function.
Well we created a calculate
monthly payment function and
we debugged it, so
it should work.
And all we need to do to
make it work is go to a
spreadsheet, type equals
calculate monthly payments and
a couple of parameters
and bang, it works.
No deployments.
If it's a visible function in
your script, visible just
means it doesn't end with an
underscore, so that you can
hide implementation details.
But if it's a visible function
in your script, then you can
just use it in a spreadsheet
immediately.
You can return a single value to
overwrite that cell, or an
array or a double array
to overwrite a range.
A slightly more complex, but
still pretty easy integration,
is to use a custom dialogue
raised from a custom menu.
The special onOpen function
lets you add menus to a
spreadsheet as it's opened.
Pretty easy code.
Spreadsheet app, get
active spreadsheet.
Add a menu, mortgage, with a
sub-menu of calculator that
calls a function
[? showcalc. ?]
Let's see how that works.
Someone clicks on mortgage
calculator.
Hey, there is the same little
calculator app that was in the
top right corner of
Bob's application.
And just like I promised, this
is an example of showing just
part of something for the
Builder inside an app.
So all we did was we added the
component from the Builder to
a script, to an app, only
showing the inner panel.
So we loaded it, but only added
an inner panel and the
calculator works exactly as
we like without the email
integration that we
showed before.
How do you distribute
something like this?
Well, there are two ways.
You can publish it to the
public script gallery.
And this public script gallery
is really public.
It's accessible from
any spreadsheet.
And for safety reasons, you can
only publish to the script
gallery from a non-domain
account,
from a Gmail.com account.
This is important because we
don't want you to accidentally
leak your personal company
enterprise assets into the
public script gallery.
In contrast, if you'd like to
publish something to your
domain, you can use the
template gallery.
That's local to your domain
and the entire spreadsheet
gets saved with the script.
So it's pretty nice if you
have a spreadsheet that
assumes a certain layout--
I'm sorry, if you have a script
that assumes a certain
layout of your spreadsheet,
you can publish it to your
domain template gallery and the
entire spreadsheet gets
put up there.
And this helps you save your
corporate assets from being
leaked out.
Here's what it looks like.
You click, sorry, Share, Publish
script, and then you
get this publisher
script dialogue.
You fill it out with the
information you like and bang.
There it is in the public
script gallery.
The flow for the template
gallery is fairly similar.
OK, how about publishing a fully
capable web app with its
own user interface?
Well the word publish in this
context means something
slightly different.
Rather than showing the code,
publishing the code so that
someone else could run the
app, we mean actually
publishing the app as an
executable that someone else
could use at a URL directly.
Here's the app.
We'd like to just make this
exist at some web page.
So in the sharing menu there's a
publish a service menu item.
You can select how you
want it to be run.
You can have it only available
to yourself for a personal
script or maybe something you're
testing, to members of
your domain, or to anybody,
where anybody either defines
any Google user, or really,
anybody, any anonymous user on
the internet.
And here's the best part.
As soon as you click Enable
service, that URL you see
there is live.
That is the entire deployment
process of Google Apps Script.
When you want to undeploy
it, uncheck the box.
That's all it takes.
No XML, no manifest. I can't
stress this enough.
OK, so I'm going to hand
this over to Drew now.
Because although I've spoken a
lot about how to build the UI,
I haven't actually told you
what to do with it.
DREW CSILLAG: Well, Corey showed
you how to build this
nice, fancy facade for building
this mortgage
application.
Unfortunately he kind of hand
waved over what I would
consider the difficult parts,
the business logic.
And some of you may have guessed
by the stuff that's in
there as going, how on earth
did they actually read the
stuff out of the inbox?
Well I get to announce that
we're rolling out the Gmail
service in the next couple of
days, which will allow you to
full access--
full fidelity access
to the Gmail inbox.
It's not through some IMAP thing
or some of the other
ways that people have done
this in the past.
So I was going to say this gives
us a great way to be
able to do all sorts of stuff.
As far as the way the API works,
if you've used Gmail--
anybody here use Gmail?
If you use Gmail, when you see
the API you're going to be
like, oh duh.
That's just the way it's
supposed to work.
And you can do all the normal
things: compose, you can check
labels, all sorts of stuff.
In Gmail, just as in the
interface, there are the main
three things.
There's threads, which contain
messages, and those messages
can be labeled.
And they could be labeled
multiple times.
The interface to deal with
labels is pretty
straightforward.
You can create them, you can
delete them, and you can get
them by either you could get all
of them or get a specific
one that you're looking for.
Within the threads, you can
get threads either by your
inbox, priority inbox, we even
allow you to get it from your
spam if you actually want
to look at your spam.
And we provide convenience
methods to get things like the
number of unread messages
in those threads.
They can also be marked as
Important or Unimportant for
like the priority inbox within
Gmail, you can mark them as
Read or Unread and you can
move them around as well.
This is my personal favorite one
because I use this all the
time, I use search
for everything.
And through the search interface
is really the longer
form version of being able to
get all the things I just
talked about before.
And in the case of going back
to the mortgage app, this is
how we're going to get the
emails that we display in that
upper left pane.
Just like whatever you could put
in that search box is the
same thing that you could
put as the argument to
GmailApp.search corrected
right there.
And then iterate over the
threads, maybe do some
additional filtering or data
munging if you want as you
loop over them, and then return
the messages back.
Well the other thing that the
mortgage app did is that at
the end of the day, it could
send a quote to the person who
originally sent the email
asking for the quote.
So also rolling out in the next
couple of days is access
to Google Documents.
This allows you to write them,
edit them, create them, the
whole nine yards.
And of course, if you're going
to work with a document, you
need to do one of two things.
You need a document
to start with.
So you can either create a new
one, you can give it a name.
Or you can get an ID from
one and open it by that.
And the IDs that we use here
are, when you've got a Google
Document open, it's got a long
string of random looking text
in the URL bar, that's what the
ID is and that's what you
would pass in.
Within the document, if you're
familiar with the W3C DOM,
it's different here.
The DOM for documents is a
little different, but it will
be very familiar to you.
Within the document there's the
body, there's paragraphs,
headers, footers, list items,
tables, all that.
For right now, headers and
footers are read only.
They will be read/write
very soon.
So in our case, what we wanted
to do for the mortgage app is
that we have this template
document that's going to
contain the relevant information
for the quote that
we're going to send them.
And so what we did is we made a
template document and we put
in these placeholder fields
right here, the start and end
with percent.
There's nothing magical about
them, it's just something
handy that we're going
to use to do a
little magic in a minute.
And Google Docs doesn't yet
support fields, so we can't
use that for field
substitution.
We've got this template
document.
And then we're going to write a
little JavaScript function.
And what it does is it goes to
the DocsList and gets the file
with the original ID
of the template.
You could do this by name
if you wanted to.
And then we make a copy of it,
and then we get the ID of the
document we just
made a copy of.
Using that we use the document
app to open it up.
We get the body content of the
document and then we just do
basic search and replace for all
the items that we wanted
to put in there.
And then we return the document
and that'll become
important a little bit later.
Now I'm going to take a little
bit of a tangent and talk
about something called blobs for
a reason that will become
clear very shortly.
First, what's a blob?
It kind of looks like that
funny-looking fish.
It's something ill-defined
or amorphous.
Some people may have the notion
of a binary large
object from a database, please
cast that from your mind.
It reminds all of bad things
and we don't want to talk
about them.
We have a bunch of different
sources and sinks of data
within Google Apps Script.
And it might be you're in
something, something and
you're putting it into your
DocsList, or you're going to
query JDBC and then post that to
some website, or do a file
upload into JDBC or
email attachment.
I mean, you kind of get this
Cartesian product of different
ways to interact with things
and very quickly, this gets
out of hand.
And nobody wants to deal
with any of this stuff.
So hence, the blob.
Anytime you're going to deal
with some massive data that's
got a name, a type, and some
measure of content to it, this
allows us to treat all these
things the same way,
regardless of where they come
from and regardless of where
they're going to be going to.
Blobs are fairly
simple things.
They have a name, like I said.
They have a content type,
which is like the
RFC style mime type.
And then they have content,
either as
bites or as a stream.
You can treat them either way,
depending upon what you want
to do with them.
The idea with a blob is that
for a lot of times you're
dealing with data, you don't
necessarily care about the
specific format of the
data that's in there.
Say you get a JPEG image
from someplace.
Most people aren't going to go
parsing through the thing,
they just want to ship it
off to something else.
But there's some cases where if
you've gotten an RSS feed
from someplace, you want to be
able to shuffle through the
thing to parse it apart.
And in some cases, depending
upon what you're doing in your
scripts, you may actually in
fact, want to create a blob
from scratch from code.
So the question is, OK, we've
got these ideas of a blobs.
What can we do with them?
Well, say we'll get a bunch of
blobs from the attachments of
this particular sites
page that we've got.
And then we've got a URL fetch
that we're going to do, go
fetch an image from someplace.
And I've got an image of my
DocsList that I want to
include too.
And then, using the new zip
functionality that we've added
to the utilities interface,
which we also have an unzip,
which works the expected way.
We can now zip all these
different things regardless of
where they came from
and produce a
zipped blob named files.zip.
And then from there, we can take
all that and then mail it
all as a attachment to
bob@example.com.
And this all just works.
One of our co-workers that we
were talking with and she had
started using it and had
mentioned, it's almost like
magic when she used
these things.
And yeah, it is kind of cool.
So why am I talking about
blobs for all of this?
Spreadsheets and documents
are blobs also
in this whole thing.
And one of the things we need
to do if we're going to mail
these things around depending
upon who gets them is we might
need to convert them in some
fashion to some form that they
can actually use.
Because maybe they don't
want a link.
So Google Docs can convert
automatically to PDF.
A lot of other types we can
convert those to PDF too.
Things that generally would have
some form of expected PDF
form that you would expect.
We can also convert between
image formats for the image
formats that are listed there.
And we also have a whole bunch
of other ideas of conversions
we'd like to be able to do.
Some things would be like take
an image, crop it, rotate it,
you could do that
as a conversion.
Or say, get the second page in
a spreadsheet, get this data
range out of it, and convert
that to a PDF, or an image, or
something else that
you could do.
Some of the more cooler things
we were thinking of is that
Google's got some really cool
stuff that can do speech
recognition and stuff.
So maybe you could convert a
WAV file to a Google Doc.
All sorts of crazy things
that we can think of.
Or doing OCR automatically
on the fly from an image.
There's a lot more things
that we want to do,
so watch this space.
So how do we actually
do the conversions?
Fortunately, it's actually
a pretty
simple matter from code.
You just say, getAs and here's
the content type that I want.
So in this particular case,
I've got a photo in my
DocsList and it's a JPEG
as it starts off and I
want it as a PNG.
Just say, getAs image PNG.
And it's that simple.
Or, if I've got my attachments
before, I can--
arrays in JavaScript have a
bunch of couple of nifty
methods that I kind of forget
that they're there.
But there's a neat one called
map, which allows me to take
an anonymous function and say
for each of the items that are
in those attachments, get them
all as application PDF.
The map function is very similar
and Python has a map
function that's very similar,
and schemes
it's the same thing.
In the Java guava-libraries
it's intervals.transform.
It shows up as it's a common
thing, where it's basically
apply this function to every
element in the original array
and return me array
of those results.
Or to spell it out a little bit
more clearly, SitesApp.
You get the original list
of attachments.
You start off with an empty
array of PDFs and then for
each of the blobs that were in
the blobs array is you push a
converted one from
the blobs array.
Or, going back to the mortgage
example, we had that
createDocument function before
and it returned the document
that it had produced.
So we're going to take that
document and then we're going
to take the message also that
we had some Gmail that we
originally started with, and
we're going to reply to it.
And then we're going to take the
document that we got that
we had created, we're going to
convert it to PDF and attach
it to that reply.
And then it's going
to send off.
And then we're going to mark the
message as read, so that
therefore when we go back to
that UI, we don't see it
anymore because it only looks
for things that were unread.
So starting with this,
we've already
got the email selected.
He's going to punch in the
$240,000 at 4%, 25 years, come
up with this payment of
$1,266.81 and he's going to
generate the reply.
He goes over to check
his email and sure
enough there's the email.
And if you look at the
attachments, there it is, the
PDF file we made.
And then opening it
up as a PDF--
because Chrome nicely
supports PDF files--
[APPLAUSE]
DREW CSILLAG: So we've
done a bunch of
boring data entry apps.
But Apps Script doesn't always
have to be that boring.
It can look really snappy
and snazzy.
And here to talk about
that is James.
JAMES FERREIRA: Well
hello everybody.
I guess we're a little
early today.
Thank you.
So I'm really, really excited to
be here talking to you all
today here at Google IO.
And I wanted to show you some
of the things that you could
do with that new GUI editor
and how we're
going to use that.
So as a developer that's always
on the go, I'm hopping
from computer to computer, one
of the things I really
appreciate about Google Script
is that it's 100% web
environment.
So while I'm developing
for the web, I can
do that on the web.
When Google Script put Script
Gadgets into sites, as
developers, we gained a lot of
ability to be able to engage
the viewers in a completely
new way that's very
interactive.
So now we can do things like
hover over pop-up menus and
informational pieces.
And this also works great for
the educational setting for
teachers to better engage
students with the information
they want to get out to them.
I wanted to show you an
app that we built.
It's called Andy.
And Andy's got a few tasks he
wants to perform to you today.
And what we have here is we have
a control panel that's a
set of buttons up at the top of
the screen that move Andy.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to head on over to
the calendar app and we're going
to retrieve a list of
Andy's events for the day.
And we can format those in a way
that matches our theme for
the application.
Now Andy can see that he's
got some work that he
needs to get done.
So he's going to go up and do
a little writing in Docs.
So here we have another list of
Andy's Docs pulled from a
specific folder in his
Google Documents.
And let's go ahead and create
a document, so we can get a
little work done here.
Now you see that automatically
updates the list there.
Well it's time for Andy
to get social.
So let's go ahead and in order
to do that we're going to have
to connect to a service that's
outside Google Script.
So here we see we're pulling in
the latest news and a Buzz
from Andy's friends using
the URL fetch app.
So say thank you, Andy.
So these are the different
scripts we used.
So what I want to do next is I
want to show you how we go
about designing a UI
like this and--
sorry, I have to stay
close to the mike--
and how we make Andy move.
So when you're building an app
in the UiApp, it's kind of
like painting a picture.
You add some [? gesso ?]
and some color and pretty soon
you have mountains and trees
and airplanes and things
like that.
In order to get depth of field
in a painting, you paint over
the top of other things and
that gives you that depth.
Well in the UiApp, when we add
things to the UiApp, they add
in the order that they were
placed on the page.
So they stack to the
lowest point.
Here we've added a couple
of grids to the
page that have stacked.
And what we can do next
is we can add in--
and you'll be able to do
this obviously, in the
GUI editor as well.
So we can add elements to each
cell within a grid and create,
basically a traditional table or
div type web page like you
would traditionally do.
What we'd like to do now is I'd
like to show you a little
bit about how you can
use CSS to position
objects on the page.
And we use the position fixed
to set items above the page,
so that we can move them.
The problem with that is
directly in our code, when we
start applying attributes, you
have to write an attribute for
every single widget that
you want to use.
And that gets really messy.
So you can do that by using
a function that will cycle
through-- you create the CSS
just as you normally would.
Write CSS in an HTML page.
And you use a function to apply
that to whatever widget
you happen to want.
So here we have a function
that will apply a given
element there.
So to make Andy move, what we're
going to do first is
we're going to set some x-,
y-coordinates in the script
properties.
That way we can access that
property from anywhere in the
script by just calling it
by, say, Get property x.
Once we've set those positions,
then we can give
Andy a starting position by
using, like I had said before,
we use the function, or we set
a CSS element, the atAndy
element, and give
him a position.
Then we can create the atAndy
image and apply the CSS, and
then he'll be in his
starting position.
To make him move we're going to
need a couple of buttons.
First we're going to create the
button, then we're going
to attach a click handler to
it that's going to fire off
the function move, and we're
going to set the idea of each
button to be the direction
that it's going to press.
Here's the move function.
And the first thing we do in
the move function is we're
going to get where Andy's
currently at by
using the get property.
We're going to set x and y.
And then we're going to run
through a series of if
statements where we're going
to check the e parameter
source to find out which
button was pressed.
And we're also going to use an
additional if that if Andy
happen to be at the side or the
top or the bottom, that
he's going to stop and it's
just going to return the
[INAUDIBLE]
directly.
Once we know which button's been
pressed, then it's just a
simple matter of incrementing or
decrementing the property.
And then we'll apply the CSS
like we did before when we set
his original start position.
That's it.
COREY GOLDFEDER: So
let me recap.
Once again, this is Bob.
And now Bob is really happy
because not only is he helping
people, he's not wasting
any time doing it.
Today we built Bob's mortgage
calculator using the brand new
GUI Builder that like I said,
is available today.
We were able to build a full
app, as well as a spreadsheet
calculator add-in.
And we deployed it as a service
and to the gallery.
We also showed you the new
Gmail service, which is
launching in the next
day or two.
Which is just as simple
as using Gmail itself.
And finally, we showed you
the document service.
Which finally has an API for
scripting Google Documents.
I keep saying finally, but we
have a lot more actually
because we showed you blobs.
Don't overthink it,
it will just work.
Take objects, attachments from
sites, attachments from Gmail,
post them directly to your
DocList. Don't worry about the
type of the object,
it will just work.
And conversions.
Some simple cases like Google
Documents to PDF
were covered today.
Stay tuned for more and
interesting ones.
Finally, James was kind enough
to show us Andy App and some
expert tips on how to use Google
Apps Script to do more
than just boring data entry.
So at this point, we'd like
to take questions.
Drew, James, and I will answer
any questions you have about
what we showed you today.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: They don't want
to hear the question.
JAMES FERREIRA: We
can hear you.
AUDIENCE: The question I have
about this new Gmail access
service, which sounds
really exciting is,
will this allow me--
it wasn't clear to me how the
user is authenticated.
You say this actually uses the
context like, for example, if
I'm trying to access the context
of a user, do we have
to use OATH or something
else like that to
authenticate the user?
JAMES FERREIRA: If you've used
like the contacts apps
interface or the calendar app.
You know how you get the auth
screen when you run it the
first time?
It's the same kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: So it will be the
same thing for that?
JAMES FERREIRA: Exactly
the same thing.
COREY GOLDFEDER: Yeah, we
do the auth for you.
So all you need to do is click
OK, I want to authorize this
and it will work.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So sounds like it's a dramatic
simplification in terms of
setting that up for us.
JAMES FERREIRA: That
was the idea.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Great.
Thank you so much for
your work on this.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any plans
to include search
as one of the services?
COREY GOLDFEDER: I don't think
we have anything to
say about that now.
I don't think anyone's currently
working on that.
But can never rule anything
out in the future.
AUDIENCE: OK.
COREY GOLDFEDER: You can always
use existing APIs.
So for example, any kind of
existing REST based API can be
hit through URL fetch.
AUDIENCE: I can't remember
from the
slide about the Gmail.
Does it access as well
the contact and the
group in the contact?
Like if you say, want to do a
mailing to a group in your
contact, can you do that?
COREY GOLDFEDER: You can access
contacts through the
existing contacts apps.
So the new Gmail app doesn't
support that because we
already have that support.
But it's there.
AUDIENCE: OK, but you can't--
can't you do like the example
you had with the document
where you send to people--
where you place--
Let's say you have a group
in your contact and your
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
and they want to use that
template in their doc to send
the same email with the PDF
attached to a group of people
replacing just the
[INAUDIBLE].
JAMES FERREIRA: You have a
contacts groups in your
contacts that you want
to be able to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you have
a group you want to--
JAMES FERREIRA: Within the
contacts app, there's actually
a way to say get me this
particular contact group and
then get the email addresses
out of there.
So from there, yeah, you'd have
the list of emails and
then you just do the
message.reply like we did
before, just with a list--
with an array of
email addresses
instead of the lone one.
AUDIENCE: So I saw the
search in Gmail.
I didn't see one in Docs.
Is there a search function
inside of the documents now?
COREY GOLDFEDER: Yeah,
it's called Find.
It's docList.Find.
It's there.
We actually showed it in
one of the slides.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I missed it.
Sorry.
COREY GOLDFEDER: I'm sorry.
Are you asking about in the
DocsList or in the new
document app?
AUDIENCE: If you had
a new document.
I guess if you have DocsList
you can find by--
I didn't think about that.
So you said document open
by ID basically, right?
JAMES FERREIRA: Yeah, it was
document open by ID.
Going through the DocsList,
you can search by name.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
The document creation and
updating features that you are
just showing, is there an API
doing the same thing?
Or do you plan to do this?
JAMES FERREIRA: I don't think
I understand the question.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Here we are using
Google Script to create a
document and to add
some custom data.
But on GData API for external
application, we can't do this.
So is there a plan to add the
possibility to create and
update documents from an
external application?
COREY GOLDFEDER:
We don't know.
We're not on that team.
JAMES FERREIRA: Yeah.
We're just providing the glue
as far as that goes.
The Docs people would
be a better people
to ask about that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I understand now
we can add an image to a
Google spreadsheet.
COREY GOLDFEDER: In general,
you mean, in spreadsheets?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
assess the image using Google
Apps Script?
COREY GOLDFEDER:
I don't believe
it's currently possible.
We try to catch up with
spreadsheet features
as they come in.
So we will probably add
that as we go on.
I do not think that's
currently possible.
JAMES FERREIRA: I don't remember
seeing it in the API
just yet, but we can
look into it.
COREY GOLDFEDER: OK, are there
any more questions?
Going once, going twice.
OK, thank everyone very much.
[APPLAUSE]